I'm Anubhuti Mishra.
And today I'm going to be
talking about allocating COVID
19 vaccines in West Africa.
So before I get
into that, I just
want to spend a few minutes
talking about my organization.
I work with Palladium
Group, which
is an international
development organization.
We work with a lot of
USAID funded projects
in West Africa
and Latin America.
I primarily work on this
big USA-funded project
called DataFi, where
we primarily work on HIV
and COVID-19 programs in
Latin America and West Africa.
So we do a lot of data
science in public health.
That involves something like
this building optimization
models to building anomaly
detection models for data
quality assessment to
building risk score models
to figure out who should be,
who in the population
is at a higher risk for HIV.
So that you can optimize
your testing resources.
So in 2021, we were
approached by a couple
of West African countries with
a very interesting problem
that there was an
influx of millions
of vaccines from Covax,
Gavi, World Bank, USA
into African countries.
But suddenly they
found themselves
with more than enough
vaccines to meet their needs.
But they found
themselves very lacking
when it comes to
supply chain issues.
Just the infrastructure
around sending vaccines
across the country.
Vaccinating millions
of adults in a period
of less than a year or 1 and
1/2 years was a huge problem.
And we found with a
little bit of research
and talking to our
country partners,
we found that a lot of countries
ended up wasting vaccines
because they were just not able
to administer those vaccines
before their expiration date.
So this was a very
interesting problem,
very different from what
we were seeing in countries
like USA or European countries.
So we thought, OK, this
is a great opportunity.
Let's build an allocation model,
let's build an optimization
model where we'll take into
consideration a lot of factors,
like time to
expiration or travel
time between distribution
centers to vaccine sites.
How many human how much staff
you have available at vaccine
sites to hesitancy
and everything.
We had a whole model in place.
But then we faced reality.
So this is what the
vaccination sites look,
look like in country.
This is a picture of a mobile
vaccine site from Cote d'Ivoire
or Ivory Coast.
And we found that data
was being collected
across different platforms.
Some sites had
tablets, some sites
had paper based data entry.
This is what vaccine
storage site looked like.
Some of the better
equipped sites
had a data entry
person with a tablet
who was able to enter patient
level data into an app.
So essentially we
found ourselves
in an extremely low
quality data environment.
So none of the pillars that
our beautiful optimization
models could stand on existed.
We found that, like I said,
data was being collected
across different platforms.
There was a lot of fragmentation
across the data collection
chain.
Then we found that
the stock data
was being collected and
managed in an Excel based tool.
There were four different
types of vaccines.
There was J&amp;J and Sinopharm
and Pfizer and AstraZeneca.
There was no data on health care
stuff available at site level.
So we suddenly found ourselves
in a very challenging
environment.
So this is where we
decided that we slightly
decided to change the
final goal of our work.
So we were no longer looking at
building an exact optimization
model that should give you the
exactly correct data on how
to allocate vaccines.
We figured that currently
the Ministry of Health
is just using whatever
happens haphazardly,
using whatever information
they have at hand, most often,
more often than not. It
is just based on what,
what is the usage rate at a
vaccination site or eligible
population.
They are not looking
at any other factors.
So we decided to use
some open source data,
pull in whatever
proprietary data
we could get from the government
and combine all of that
to create a vaccine
allocation tool.
So this is a list of all
sorts of open source data
that we pulled into our tool.
We pulled in population
data from WorldPop.
There were there was
data on health care sites
across Sub-Saharan Africa.
Then we were able to use
a bunch of R packages
to calculate travel time,
to calculate catchment area
for vaccine sites.
And that combined with
a lot of country data.
So even the list of
data sets listed here
were not available at the start.
We had to and we are still
working with the country a lot
to get these data sets.
They are they started
collecting data
on healthcare staff
available at the site level
after we requested them to
share that data with us.
We are working with them on
how to collect these data
sets in a routine and a
systemic, systematic format.
So then this was our approach
to creating this vaccine
allocation tool where we would
combine a bunch of open source
data with country specific data
and create this tool, which
gives you some sort
of an estimate for how
to allocate vaccines.
We are no longer asking
the Ministry of Health
to look at this
tool as an end all,
be all for allocating vaccines.
They should be looking
at their ground realities
and comparing with the
suggestions from this model
and then making their decisions
on how to allocate the tool.
So when it came to where to
build this tool, we wanted to
and several I think
all the presenters
before me have mentioned
that when you are working
in public sector, you're often
working with extremely low data
environment.
Low cost is always an
issue, so you're always
relying on open source tools.
So we wanted to
build a low cost,
easy to use interactive
and portable app.
And then of course,
Shiny is the only thing
that came to all our minds.
So we built a Shiny app and
this is what the landing
page looks like. It exists in.
Let me start this.
Yeah it exists in both
English and French right now.
So the app lets you change
the input language so
that because most of our
country staff speaks French.
Cote d'Ivoire is a
French dominant country.
None of the nobody on the data
science teams speaks French.
So we have an English
version for ourselves.
So this is our Shiny app
and you will see that,
on some of the other tabs,
we still have text in
both English and French.
That's for our
internal reference.
This app has still
not been rolled out.
But OK?
Yeah so this the second tab
called Stoock Data essentially
just displays all the
stock data that we
processed from the
ministry's Excel based tool.
You can look at what types of
vaccines are available, their
batch number, their expiration
date, number of doses,
number of vials available.
And we use this information
to build the allocation model.
Then we have the
Distribution Network which
displays the distribution
network for Cote d'Ivoire.
In Cote d'Ivoire, the vaccines
come to a national distribution
center.
From there, they go to
regional distribution center,
which from there on, they go to
district level, a distribution
center, and then from there
they are sent to vaccine sites.
We've divided these
into separate maps
because obviously it was very
difficult to view everything
in a single map.
So on the left hand side,
you can see this regional
to district level
distribution maps.
And then on the right hand
side, you can see them.
The connection between the
center, the national level
distribution center.
The regional
Then these are the location
of all the vaccination
sites across the country.
So in our input data, we do
have the entire distribution
network.
So which sites are assigned
to which districts.
And this is a list of
all vaccination sites.
And users can come in here and
they can select or unselect
any vaccination sites,
because we often
see that the Ministry will roll
out during they'll have periods
of vaccine campaigns where
they will roll out 50 to 100
additional vaccine,
mobile vaccination sites.
So that can be added here.
And then when they're
done with them,
they can be removed
from the model.
So you can see users can
come in and check or
uncheck, and then they
can save the list
of vaccine sites.
Once that is done, they
can go over to the Proposed
Distribution tab.
This allows you the
first user input here
we have is number of days.
Because of the
complexity of the model,
we needed to ascertain how many
days does the Ministry have
to allocate these
number of vaccines.
So they can decide here that
we have these current batches
and based on the
expiration date,
we want to allocate
all of these vaccines
in the next 20 days or 30 days.
They are, the default
we've used this 30 days,
based on the
ministry's feedback
and they can save
this information
and then run the model.
So once all of this
information is saved,
we click this button
to run the model which
will produce your proposed
distribution maps.
So this takes a few seconds,
but this is essentially
a linear optimization
model with
in with constraints
around expiration date,
time to vaccinate,
eligible population. We
will walk through the list
of constraints
in a bit.
So this is the proposed.
This is a distribution map
that is generated by the app.
You can look at
the map and then,
if you hover over any
of the vaccine sites,
it will show you the name, the
regional depot and the district
depot
that site is connected to,
and the number of vaccines
of each type allocated
to that vaccine site.
So here we can see
that this site has
been allocated only Sinopharm.
So 722 doses of Sinopharm
and none of the other ones.
Then we can see here
the site has been
allocated 916 doses of Pfizer.
So, so on and so forth.
You can click on any of the
site and look at how many doses
have been allocated
to that particular side.
Then there's the map
below, where, of course,
the above map was a
little difficult to read.
So you can filter this
map on whichever district.
You want to look at.
And here we've
selected the Abobo
East, and you can
zoom in and look at the
number of vaccines allocated
to each of the vaccination
sites connected to this district
distribution center.
So yeah, this is basically
the model once this
is done,
you can.
Users can go over
to the Results tab
where they can view all of these
results in a tabular format.
They can see which how many
doses of each type of vaccine
has been assigned to
each vaccination site.
They can download these results,
share it with their team,
and make decisions
based on this.
Then we just have a tab
for Model Documentation.
But this is
the Shiny app for
vaccine allocation tool.
We still haven't launched it.
Next month we are going
to have a training
session with our
Ministry of Health
and their COVID-19
COVID-19 team in country.
And once this is done, we
will be transitioning it
off to the team.
So that they can update and use
this tool for making decisions,
allocation decisions
going forward.
So like I said,
this is essentially
a linear optimization problem
where our main focus was
our decision variable
was to figure out
how many vaccines should
be allocated to each site.
And the optimisation objective
was to minimize wastage
and while maximizing
the number of people
vaccinated in the eligible
population. And we ran into,
we started with a smaller
list of constraints,
but over time we ran into
as you work with the data,
you figured out some
additional constraints.
So it included that.
We had to rank
prioritize batches based
on their time to expiration.
So not only did we have four
different types of vaccines
for each type of vaccine, you
could have multiple batches.
So we had to make sure
that the model starts
to allocate the batches
that expire first
before it allocates batches that
have more time to expiration.
Then we yeah, we had to there
were a lot of constraints
around expiration
date, making sure
that it's delivered
and administered
before its expiration
date, that there
are enough people to administer
those vaccines at the site.
So yeah, this is the,
our vaccine allocation tool.
There was a lot of
hesitancy from the Ministry
initially about using R
and R Shiny. As a lot of you
might know that normally
in public health care,
especially in Africa,
countries tend
to use these as two platform.
So they were extremely
hesitant to work
with a new platform, a
separate one for their COVID 19
vaccination needs.
But once they saw what we
did to bring them on board
was that before we even got
any data from the country,
we build a mock app, we
travel to the country,
we had a training requirements
gathering workshop.
We showed them the app.
They were able to use it
and see how useful it can
be for their decision making.
And that was essentially all
we needed to get them on board.
And since then they
have been extremely
active and instrumental in
ensuring that we receive
all the data that we need.
We have regular meetings
with the Ministry
of Health folks and
their COVID-19 task force
to ensure that they are
abreast with all the changes
that are happening that we
are making to the model.
And we are still figuring
out some of the challenges
with transitioning this tool
over to the country team.
Like I said, you know, they
this is a new tool for them.
They don't have R
programmers on their team.
So we will be continuing
to work with the Ministry
to figure out those challenges.
But yeah, and.
That's where my talk ends.
I would like to advertise
this a little bit
since I got a chance that I
am hiring a senior associate
in data science.
Ours is a small but
growing team and we work
on very interesting problems.
We don't have huge
data sets, but we do
build very interesting models.
So do get in touch with
me if you have any.
If you're interested.
OK it's like anybody.